Film Courage: I would imagine this comes up
a lot.
If I write Hollyshorts a letter “I would
love it if you can waive the [film festival
submission] fee and I will do this…this…this…to
reciprocate for that money.”
Are you able to then take my submission and
waive that fee?
Daniel Sol, Co-Founder of the Hollyshorts
Film Festival: My answer to that would be
“No.”
Yes, we are not a fan of fee-waiver requests.
Many festivals probably agree with me, maybe
some don’t offer a lot of waivers.
The only instance is if I go to a festival
and I see your film and say I’ve got to
have it.
If I’m essentially at your door begging
you for your film then obviously in fairness
I’m telling you to submit.
Worse case offer you a discount or waive the
fee.
But I don’t really do that anymore, we don’t
ask for films really at all.
It’s not about the financial aspect, it’s
about the fairness of the process.
If you feel your film is worthy of that, well
many others are too.
So why are we waiving one fee just because
you asked for it and everyone else is paying
full price.
What’s the difference?
Why should I offer you this nice gift?
For what?
Just to ask for it is not a good enough reason.
Even if there are extenuating situations or
we hear all sort of stuff whether it’s financial
stuff obviously for student filmmakers.
Obviously money is tight, you’re in college,
you’re a student, I get that part.
You have to pick which festival you are going
to submit to and you have to make a plan.
You’ve got to just make something happen.
You can’t just say I want a fee waiver because
I’m having some struggles.
We all have struggles, we all have things.
I was in college and broke.
I had to pay for certain things that I wanted.
You have to make it happen.
You don’t just ask for it because you feel
you deserve it.
To me there is a certain element…it’s
offensive.
I personally don’t like it.
I will try to answer as many as I can.
I tell people we just do not take waivers
and that’s it.
At times if there are certain times where
we like the email and someone is making a
good effort, there’s a real reason behind
something or whatever I don’t know we can
always say look there are certain situations
where we have discounts with promo partners
and things.
Look them up and if they send their code out
and if they have a discount there, you have
a discount.
But that’s all we can do, you still have
to pay.
It’s still the principal of it, everybody
is submitting and paying.
So if you get accepted and you don’t pay
and then they paid their money and they didn’t
get in or they got in why are you getting
the same equal benefit?
Every dollar counts but it’s not like you
are submitting $500.00 to submit to a festival.
Now it adds up for a lot of festivals, I get
that.
Our fee is what our fee is.
I don’t care what other festivals charge
or how many other festivals you’re submitting
to.
For us we look at it as you should submit
to ours.
We feel it’s in that caliber and it’s
in the range of $35.00 to $70 or so dollar
range of early to late.
If you submit it on the last day, it’s higher.
If you submit to early bird it’s anywhere
from $35 to $40 dollars.
It’s not something you will need to donate
blood for.
And again, I don’t want to come across as
too flippant or anything.
It’s just to me is something that takes
time from my day or any of our days, or interns
or assistants to answer these emails, which
some of them we can’t even catch up on.
Or some of them we wonder why even bother
answering, like do I have to answer you?
I don’t have to but we are trying to at
least be kind enough to get back to you and
say “Look we just don’t offer waivers.”
It’s not even a time thing, it’s a principal
thing like why is everyone else paying and
what makes you different and feel you’re
more special that you don’t have to pay?
Based on not just struggle but just my film
is that good…and that bugs me even more!
Filmmakers should never reference “I played
at this festival, that festival so that means
obviously I’m at a certain place, I’ve
gotten into some festivals.
But now waive my fee for this one.”
Okay, let me ask you this, did you submit
to those festivals and pay?
Yeah right…yes you did.
I’m assuming yes.
So okay now you’re telling me my festival
is not worthy of submitting the fee and paying.
You got into those festivals…do you see
the hypocrisy of that?
That bugs me to no end.
You’re telling me you’ve played these
festivals already so obviously we can assume
you paid the submission fee, I highly doubt
they gave you the waivers.
And at times I would actually get mad and
I used to say it to people.
I would say “Oh so did you pay this fee?”
No answer.
You paid their fee, so you’re telling me
now you’re not going to pay our submission
fee at a moderate rate because you played
there already and you just don’t want to
pay our fee.
Do you not inherently notice how offensive
that can be to a festival?
You’re telling me we played them first but
it’s going to be personal.
You’re telling me you played there and paid
there and you don’t want to pay for us.
You’re saying now you ran out of money and
you don’t want to pay?
Or you don’t want to pay period?
Or you are going to ask for something because
you have some more special thing going because
you’ve been accepted.
So it’s great.
Awesome that these films come to us.
We know they made these festivals, all good.
But everyone else is paying so…
I know there are other circumstances where
there are other countries such as Iran comes
up a lot, they cannot pay fees or there is
sanctions on credit cards that we hear about.
I don’t know the political situation of
how this is fully accurate or not.
I believe it is to be.
We still get submission from Iran at times
and they pay.
I don’t know how they do or with what?
But they come in and they do.
And those that don’t, we get emails from
there everyday probably five emails from there
a day (maybe 10) asking for fee waivers.
I can’t open the floodgates there.
If I say yes and no one pays then all of these
films get to not pay but everyone else is
paying.
I’ve even asked people “Can someone else
pay for you?”
There are other countries where people have
some money in the States or LA or whatever.
Offer discounts or whatever, but it’s the
principal.
If you’re just offering all of these waivers
for people.
Now we have to spend our time and resources
for staff to watch these films, this doesn’t
work for us.
I don’t see it as something that is fair.
I know it is tough for those countries with
sanctions.
That’s a tough situation but we haven’t
found a way to solve that.
We’re just being honest.
I know some festivals just completely waive
fees for Iran, feeling like they can’t pay
and that kind of stuff.
It’s not something we can do with our resources
and our team size.
So we don’t, we’re not a proponent of
that and many times with the emails, if it’s
not with any good effort…look people always
say “You get what you ask for.”
You’ve got to ask.
You don’t ask, you don’t receive.
If you don’t ask and throw it out there,
why not?
But if you do submit, fine.
If you ask for a waiver and I say fine and
you don’t submit, now your film never plays
and never gets in and what’s the point of
all that?
If you put that time into those emails, you
could put your time into something else.
Film Courage: Well I’m not going to go into
the local coffee shop and say “Hey can you
give me this one latte for free this time?”
Daniel: Exactly.
To me there is nothing different.
I don’t even see how they can look at it
as anything different.
And that’s exactly the point.
It’s a good analogy.
You’re not going to walk into some store
and say “Give me this for free just because.”
Whether we have struggled or not, everyone
has had some struggle.
Again I was in position of real struggle in
college and you find a way to survive and
get by.
You don’t just ask for things just because
you feel you’re in a different place or
more special than anyone else or you don’t
want to pay just because you don’t want
to.
So those kind of emails I just don’t understand.
You’re just basically telling me you just
don’t feel like paying so you’re going
to ask.
It’s really odd to me.
If you think about any other business, like
if people all went to Starbucks and they had
10 people day all asking for a free cup of
coffee, it’s not happening.
And imagine if it was and you’re like “No!”
It’s really a bizarre thing.
I guess it’s something that is like just
part of this business and it’s inherent
but it’s definitely different and unique
to this because Starbucks is not getting bombarded
every day with customers saying “Hey I want
this for free this time.”
This is definitely a pet peeve for many festivals
and programmers I’d imagine (I’m speaking
for others) Maybe some don’t care about
it much or like it but I’d imagine most
are not appreciative of emails all the time
spent on that…so definitely I’d say just
don’t.